tonight ccsd meeting well underway
things have already turned tense one
teacher started yelling that she quote
resigned and then just ran right out of
the room in fact brian hundreds of
people have gathered to protest a
potential staff vaccine mandate as
trustees are set to vote on a possible
policy tonight sasha loftis pre-recorded
tonight's story as many protesters have
already spiraled out of control
tonight's meeting is well underway but
there is still a line of people looking
to get into the clark county government
building here to attend the meeting and
to speak out and have their voices heard
now tonight is already heated as
trustees are set to vote on whether to
move forward with the covid 19 vaccine
mandate for district employees this
special meeting follows the lead of
several other districts around the
nation that have taken this action one
reason district leaders are considering
this many kids are still too young to
get vaccinated if the school board votes
for the resolution today this would give
superintendent dr jesus joe the power to
establish a vaccine policy now if this
resolution does move forward tonight no
word on when it would go into effect or
be enforced now as of today there are
sixteen hundred and fifty one positive
covet cases across the clark county
school district 980 of those cases are
students now we have heard from both
sides of this a lot of people
impassioned saying that they do not want
a vaccine mandate for staff other people
are saying that they are for it because
they believe it keeps their students
safer and we will of course have the
latest coming up at 11 o'clock tonight
and have the latest online on eight news
now dot com as this meeting continues
reporting downtown tonight sasha loftis
8 news now sasha thank you the school
district also asking your opinion on
where to use
770 million dollars in federal funds it
is called the focus on the future for
kids community input process you can
head to future.ccsd.net
also have a link to do so on our website